chan on est aujourd'hui c'était le
lancement de des one + 7 témoins depuis
si tu es pro est aujourd'hui lors va
rentrer c'est là que le week-end le
temps de rentrer de se poser un peu
avant de repartir pour une grosse
semelle la semaine prochaine direction
new york lisbonne enfin vous expliquer
ça la semaine prochaine je sais pas si
vous connaissez un petit peu qu'ils sont
très longs débats excellent excellent
fait des deux palais des expositions
avec ici vous avez un notaire gdm reste
peu de pays où fait un énorme ulliott
mais c'est à elliott hôtel moi je suis
pas un chat potté que le nouveau tel
mais le truc tu es assez ou sur les
docks
c'est plutôt cool alors comme d'hab je
mets offerts faire une petite visite de
la chambre vous sert un retour express
pour vous montrez vous faire visiter
qu'ensuite on file direction le youtube
space
rendez vous ce matin avec matchs-aller
manager justin après la maison et puis
refaire aujourd'hui une petite faq
regardez-moi ça comme c'est mignon des
petites chambres petit canapé sympathie
pour bien bosser on a encore bossé un
bureau bon ranger ses petites affaires
pas mal et la salle de bains vraiment
cool et en dépenses à la somme c'est
tout mignon tout ça voilà on n'arrête
pas de vous re était derrière vous avez
la porte miroir du miroir de tous les
côtés sans plus schizophrène
oh
enfin temps magnifique aujourd'hui voyez
petite heure entre gris pluvieux bon sa
visite au tour si google pour faire un
retour sur la chaîne par contre ça se
passe juste là ou pas si vous connaissez
plutôt bien positionné voilà j'ai perdu
un peu ma voix hrl journée est un petit
peu rudement ont fait ça un avion dans
quelques heures et ensuite on se refile
la facture soit l'aéroport sont ensuite
allés voter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de retour au studio je n'ai pas tourné à
jouer faire la faq directement depuis
aéroports mais au final le temps de tout
préparer tout le monde voilà c'est un
peu compliqué beaucoup de monde bien
revenu de l'ong c'était vachement bien
il y avait quoi de plus je sais pas si
vous avez regardé la vidéo mais si c'est
pas le cas je vous invite à aller jeter
un petit coup d'oeil au delà de parler
du produit a passé une très bonne
journée entre influent sur les
journalistes c'était vraiment cool de
vie les choses vachement intéressant dit
quand on s'est bien marré et on l'a
partagée en sicile à partager dans la
vidéo alors aujourd'hui faq il ya plein
de questions je vais essayer de tous
vous répondre et je vous invite dès
maintenant a marqué toutes vos questions
pour la prochaine faq
alors il ya beaucoup de questions pour
savoir quels premiers choisir entre tel
modèle tel modèle est tel modèle je
réponds bien évidemment question mais je
peux pas répondre à tous parce qu'après
ça fait que des faq pour vous aider à
choisir les produits
ça va pas forcément intéresser tout le
monde donc il n'est pas poser toutes vos
questions pour les questions que sur les
produits il ya le forum qui arrivera
bientôt on en reparlera plus tard leur
nombre alors on y va on recommence
je préfère de loin dans cela générique
il appuya me ok pas de souci
bizarre je ne vois pas le bouton
rejoindre d'ailleurs il ya celle où
tours jaunes qui arrivait ya pas
longtemps là vous avez ici en bas je
sais plus quel côté de comblement ici
peut-être que ce n'est pas disponible
dans ma zone géographique ps on vous
suit depuis il a connu ça y est nous en
côte d'ivoire alors effectivement le
bouton rejoindre n'est pas disponible
dans tous les pays il ya beaucoup paix
dans lequel il n'a dit si tu ne vois pas
ce qu'il est pas tout de suite
disponible en côte d'ivoire mais
peut-être qu'il arrivera plus tard
penses tu que tu testera un jour des
chromebook trop notamment hp ou un cerf
probablement probablement probablement
ça ça arrive hein ça se développe
vachement donc que c'est possible qu'on
en reparle très prochainement il
préférable d'acheter un smartphone haut
de gamme qui est sorti il y a deux ans
trois ans ou un smartphone milieu de
gamme c'est cette année pour le même
prix
exemple galaxie essuie-tout shiomi
minefe c'est une question qui très bonne
qui est souvent compliqué ça ne dépend
très souvent du smartphone vous et toute
cette catégorie des flagships killer
vous aurez de choses qui sont plus
performantes aujourd'hui avec ces
produits là qu'avec des produits dits ya
deux trois ans ça dépend en prime fait
plus de louey ça dépend de ce que vous
voulez faire voilà il ya plein de choses
à y réfléchir mais moi smartphones haut
de gamme dit ya deux trois ans par
rapport à ce qu'on trouve aujourd'hui
dans le milieu de gamme je suis pas sûr
que ce soit vraiment très très
intéressant après tout qui peut être
intéressant c'est un truc qui est assez
récent et reconditionnés ça peut être
pas mal c'est la course aux pixels est
ce pour autant gage de qualité photo
très clairement
c'est pas le nombre de pixels qui fait
la qualité photo et je les dis dans ma
dernière faq mais par exemple les 48
mégapixels sortent souvent des photos en
12 mégapixels mais ces gros nombre de
pixels les capteurs plus large qui
servent à capter plus de lumière c'est
un petit peu ça l'idée derrière moi
après ça dépend comment c'est utiliser
aussi du point de vue logiciel derrière
mais effectivement c'est parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de pixels que c'est forcément
mieux pourquoi les marques telles que
xiaomi red mist shiomi rémy c'est la
même chose au pot n'investissent pas les
marchés africains comme par exemple
plaindre il ya de l'argent alors je
pense que ça dépend des stratégies bien
évidemment lors qu'une marque comme
xiaomi ou au pot attaque un nouveau
marché
ils peuvent pas se positionner de
partout déjà le marché européen très
gros je pense que pour très transparent
que le l'afrique et pour moins
intéressant tout de suite en termes de
revenus que l'europe dont les attaques
d'abord l'europe mais in fine et je suis
persuadé que ses marques pour finir de
se développer pour continuer leur
développement et qu'on les verra un
moment où notre arrivée en afrique je
souhaite changer mon me 9,6 me constitue
de prendre le one + 7 pro ou d'attendre
louane +7 et prônant les deux sont
sortis quelle différence il ya je te dis
ça dans ma vidéo de diwan +7 et projets
explique les différences mais les deux
sont très très bien en ce qui concerne
la communauté il est regrettable de
devoir payer pour faire partie de cette
famille dreux il n'y aurait pas moyen de
faire des dons gratuits par
l'intermédiaire de visualisation de
publicité comme nous n'avons pas tous
les moyens de mettre de l'argent tous
les mois
patrick je te rassure tu fais partie de
la coupe de thé grrrr quand tu es là tu
mets des commentaires tu regardes tu
fais partie de la communauté le côté je
dirais de personnes qui peuvent me
soutenir financièrement c'est cool mais
c'est pas obligatoire et puis tu sais
c'est pas parce que il y en a qui le
font qu'ils peuvent ou qu'ils veulent
mais c'est pas du tout obligatoire et
c'est pas parce qu'on le fait pas qu on
ne soutient pas l'idée de regarder que
de la publicité mis bout-à-bout pour que
ça verse un peu d'argent moi je suis pas
fan de ça j'aime pas la démarche de dix
ans vous abreuve de publicité on voulait
mais dans votre tête pour ça me ramène
un peu d'argent moi je suis pas d'accord
qui est de la publicité sur youtube
avant de regarder la vidéo
comme vous avez la publicité à la télé
c'est normal parce que le contenu
gratuit mais de vous dire je vais donner
de l'argent le créateur et je regardais
de la publicité pendant un repas commun
tant pour sa part ça moi ça je ça me
semble déranger je n'aime pas trop ce
site à quelles marques célèbres de
coques de protection constitue une gêne
importante derrière décrit docile donc
bien évidemment conseil et le coq rhino
side
je voudrais acheter le au nord 20 pro
vous savez
s'il en vaut la peine qu'elle a l'air
intéressant l'honore d'impro très
intéressant c'est un des smartphones les
plus haut de gamme de cheonan
moi je trouve cool pour la prochaine
focus je voudrais savoir comme beaucoup
je change de téléphone comme un
engagement avec un opérateur a expiré
est ce une bonne idée ou et mes
d'acheter un téléphone directement nu de
toute façon le smartphone que vous
lâchez un opérateur ou chance opérateur
vous l'achetez d'une manière ou d'une
autre effectivement pas sur un opérateur
on le sent un peu moins passé parce que
on lisse mensuellement
mais d'une manière ou d'une autre
téléphone on le paye moi je préfère
effectivement acheté mon téléphone nu
parce que s'ils cassent si du coup je
dois en racheter ainsi pas pris
d'assurance
eh bien ça m'embête de devoir toujours
payer l'autre avec mon opérateur après
vous savoir que la france implique un
peu exceptionnel on achète
effectivement avec opérateurs mais que
dans le reste du monde généralement été
dévoilé sa technique mois là c'est un
peu une petite différence française
dans tous les cas je préfère avoir un
abonnement moins cher qui correspond
vraiment un mésusage 15 euros 20 euros
maxi par mois mais vraiment maxi maxi à
10 ou 15 euros par mois des gens
trouvent un forfait qui est très bien
qui marche parfaitement bien en france
d'être des fois à l'étranger et vous
achetez votre téléphone nu correspond à
votre budget a beau visage et les trucs
sont très bien tous les pneus me
conseilles tu entre le samsung galaxy à
70 et le pétrole ait que je dirais
peut-être lui à 70 iphone c'est tout
galaxy et suit là la question se pose du
point de vue de l' os est ce que tu
préfères android ou ios et j'aime bien
les deux j'aime bien le design du et
suit mais je gardais et phone 7 cette
réponse là le s suite est il toujours
intéressant aujourd'hui je pense pas que
ce soit le ensuite le plus intéressant
aujourd'hui surveille sur un smartphone
un peu plus vieux je pense que le s9 et
bien parce qu'à partir du s9 vous avez
la caméra ouverture variable iphone
c'est tout un web est remplie iphone 7
samsung galaxy s suite ou iphone 8
je dirais iphone 8 c'est quoi ta
technique pour compte apprécié tous
autant qu'on travaille les la définition
du terme gérance sans léchage de bottes
clairement telle inspiration d'un écoute
merci beaucoup
car sur toi et d'ailleurs merci je fais
partie de la team gros jeux
vois que tu es souvent l'art sur twitter
sur youtube donc merci gros bisous
j'ai l'honneur demain que je trouve
super sur tous les points mais penses tu
que les smartphones au nord sont trop
sous coté par rapport à huawei honor
c'est une noble stratégie mais sur une
cible plus jeune
du côté de chez au nord ils vont pas
sortir les mêmes produits avec les mêmes
exigences du très haut de gamme que
huawei moi je trouve pas que ce soit son
côté ils ont une stratégie très
différente une stratégie plus digital
à propos de la déco ton studio je te
propose que nous désabonner réserve un
mur de gloire sur lequel on va poster
des crues du jour signature graphique
etc
ça c'est une superbe super super super
idée de mettre en place les faits que
vous m'envoyez tu pars à des dessins des
photos ce que vous voulez et que vous
réserve une place dans le studio
on va mettre ça en place j'ai vous
donnez à l'adresse très prochainement
d'ailleurs dit moi avant toute chose ça
vous intéresse
est ce que vous seriez prêt vous à
m'envoyer des choses une photo une
création ce que vous voulez parce que le
mois en bas en commentaire
je trouve ça vraiment vraiment ultra
cool super super super idée blacksad de
ou rock funk de rock band 2 plus
performants et les accessoires à rome et
dans mathijsen salut matrix aimes tu as
déjà été malade lors d'un voyage que tu
as fait surtout que le décalage horaire
des eaux de l'île maurice l'île maurice
fondant est ce que je disais tu es
malade alors pas lors de mes voyages
presse je touche du bois
j'espère vraiment pas ça ouvre sa saga
j'ai déjà été malade j'ai passé un mois
au nigeria à quelques bonnes années
j'avais 23 ans je crois et j'étais
malade
voilà mes jeux une gastro c'est ce truc
un peu jamais très très drôle
pourquoi je fais ce bruit ne voient pas
très drôle en tout cas d'ailleurs je
vous parle du nigeria les 100 matchs de
rechercher nigeria je raconte un peu le
périph dans une limite toute première
vidéo nous et voir c'était un souvenir
très très très bas pendant tout cas
bonjour monsieur creux pourquoi ne
testez vous pas des smartphones de la
marque archos je suis absolument pas
complété ce n'est d'ailleurs comme si
vous m'envoyez smartphone vous pouvez me
contacter et ça sera avec grand plaisir
toby fera une présentation du mèdes 20 5
g je pense pas on part à la 5g l'année
prochaine la 5g va arriver en france en
2020 moi je sais que j'ai pas plus dense
française il ya la suisse pour l'instant
car la 5g ça démarre doucement doucement
doucement la 5g donc
on en reparlera le maître vincent jay
non non je pense qu'on en reparlera j'ai
un doute avec le samsung galaxy fold ou
moins de +7 des pros lequel prendre tous
les mêmes produits je pas si ton message
est très très sérieux d'ailleurs c'est
pas tous la même chose le foll dont
l'essor des smartphones une liga qui
coûte plus de 1000 euros de san suu kyi
très bien one + 7 des pros qui est aussi
excellent c'est pas le même budget c'est
pas le même produit c'est pas le même
prix sont de trucs vraiment différent si
tu veux t'offrir le foll
tu te fais un cadeau tu achète un
produit d'exception mais si tu veux un
produit qui est très bon qui va
parfaitement bien le one piece est des
pros est juste parfait géant huawei mais
ils disent non pro je ne sais pas par
quoi le remplacer une marque d'intérêt
sont huawei xiaomi meizu hésite donc en
train prochain 1905 g7 habite en suisse
5 g pourquoi pas sinon je le déconseille
les mx 4 may 30 pro ou non promis 9 des
projets dans toute publicité kanak sont
pas sorties déjà il y en a que je n'ai
pas eu en main dans tout ce que tu as
dit en tout cas le mil neuf pros je le
connais il est très bien je te conseille
quel téléphone vous conseillerais aux
alentours des 100 euros du neuf ou
reconditionnés ou alors 100 euros les
sur un budget qui pas très élevé un
charlie je te conseille d'aller sur dur
reconditionnés tu trouveras des produits
que tu mourrais pu avoir en retour
d'entre 200 à 300 euros qui du coup
seront meilleurs que du neuf en termes
de performance pour un produit de
l'année dernière en reconditionnés tu
peux tourner truc cool je suis persuadé
regarde côté de chez chuo millien réduit
notre 5 qui est toujours cool pour
d'actualité galaxy tab est sis au ipad
trop mois pour moi la question là dessus
c'est l'os est ce que tu veux un ipad os
ou alors est ce que tu veux plutôt aller
du côté d'android
après ça dépend évidemment des
applications ça dépend des usages les
deux sont très bons le galaxy tab est ce
si ce sera moins cher qu'un ipad pro
mais une fois de plus ça dépend ce que
tu veux je me demande entre l'iphone 6
aces plus et le sais plus lequel choisir
le set plus pour moi il ya une évolution
une vraie évolution intéressante entre
l'iphone 6 s et l'iphone 7 alors plus ou
peu plus ça change pas il ya une vraie
évolution
il ya une évolution de moi fera moins
flagrante entre l'iphone cette année
phone 8
donc pour moi le set plus top si tu
devais choisir entre le dernière xperia
et dernier nokia que prendrais tu ça
dépend de l'xperia bien évidemment si tu
pars serein xperia one ou sur un modèle
haut de gamme de chez sony
ça marche c'est cool les écrans sont
vraiment bien sages conseils est ce
qu'un
1 un jour pourras-tu organisé une soirée
abonnés clermontoise peut-être une bonne
idée à réfléchir en tout cas si on le
fait on sera probablement mayerling
salut tu me conseilles quoi entre le one
+ 7 pro et le samsung s 10 ça dépend de
ce que tu veux en faire si tu veux les
sens de la photo si pour toi la photo
c'est être plus important le s10 ça un
peu meilleur aura rendu un peu plus
naturel je préfère le entre celui du s10
à celui d'ubs en plus cette pro j'aime
beaucoup de voix de plus cette promesse
je préfère après si tu veux aller du
point de vue de l'écran le dit c'est
très bon pour filtrer la lumière bleue -
de plus cette pro sera le meilleur est
le 90 s avec plus de fluidité c'est à
mon avis là dessus qu'il faut se baser
pour faire son choix ça dépend de
plusieurs de ce que toi tu vas en clair
samsung à 70 ou chez omis 1999 des pros
plus performants me conseilles tu le web
et cela n'aide pas il écoule qu'est ce
que tu penses de la vie mais j'adore la
vie c'est la croque à pleines dents le
dell xps 13 2018 ou lasserre swift celle
de 1019 très important ça dépend une
fois de plus ce que tu veux si tu veux
un truc extrêmement fins très léger très
profonde très profilé très très
minimaliste le swift c'est 2019
l'expert stress 2018 est vraiment bien
tu auras pas la même taille d'écran et
puis après il faut choisir différentes
configurations de performance entre un
produit et l'autre une bombe à la
différence elle va être jouée en termes
de design de finesse le swift 7 est plus
petit et tu rends plus compte et donc ça
dépend si tu as plus de combats tous
pensent à lui tu ne conseillerai quoi
comme smartwatch entre la galaxie watch
46 mm galaxie watch actif deux fossiles
cinquième génération ou huawei watch gt2
alors là borrowed gt2 je la mets un peu
de côté un peu différente
il ya des trucs à revoir un peu sur
l'eau est sale intéressante mais jamais
de côté la faucille cinquième génération
elle est cool pour l'autonomie la
gestion train de tester la galaxie watch
active 2 pour l'instant autonomie a
trouvé excellente ça fait deux jours que
je l'utilisent et je suis à combien sur
51 % d'autonomie vraiment cool
la galaxie watch et j'adore avec la
grosse molette physique il hésiterait
entre la galaxie watch active 2 vous
venez comme salle avec vos doigts vous
avez un touché là ça devient vraiment
bouger ça joue ça vraiment vraiment
vraiment cool c'est un tout qui manquait
que la galaxie watch active un donc ça
trouve vraiment cool
je suis entre lacs pour moi le
s'activent 2 et la faucille cinquième
génération peut-être la watch active de
salut c'est vrai que tous les téléphones
ont des composants samsung dans tous les
téléphones non pas des composants
samsung marseille si vous avoir c'est
que je pense que vous le savez samsung
c'est une énorme boîte
là je sais pas vous dire de bêtises mais
je crois alors 20% du pib de la corée du
sud tout juste monstrueux nous on
connaît beaucoup samsung pour les
smartphones les tablettes et les télés
mais en fait ça me manque beaucoup de
choses en ce corps et ça me saoule les
présents dont beaucoup beaucoup de
domaines par exemple ça me saoule dans
l'automobile faisons un partenariat avec
le renault samsung automobile le truc
est assez dingue
vous avez des climatiseurs enfin samsung
est partout qui sont présents bien
évidemment sur les écrans sur les puces
il ya pas mal pas mal de choses donc il
n'ya pas du samsung partout mais c'est
vrai qu'en tout cas samsung au niveau
des écrans est connue et reconnue et
notamment dans les smartphones
donc on retrouve souvent des écrans de
samsung dans les smartphones pour la
rencontre abonné je pense que les trois
cent mille cinq cent mille abonnés
serait bien c'est une très bonne idée on
va regarder ça le jeu je vous disais un
million parce que je voulais faire un
gros truc mais on pourrait faire un truc
être un peu moins grands avant je sais
pas on revoit mais en tout cas je crois
deviner quel est l'avenir de sony dans
la téléphonie
c'est une très bonne question d'une
façon globale c'est compliqué d'avoir
une vision un petit peu un moyen et à
long terme sur toutes les marques en
fait dans la téléphonie parce que le
marché est extrêmement fluctuants
extrêmement changeant avec une très
grosse concurrence sony pas dans une
position très très simple et ils ont
souffert et rue du mal à se renouveler
il tente aujourd'hui des choses il tente
vraiment avec le 21 9ème avec des
formats un peu différent en se
positionnant sur ce qu'ils savent faire
l'écran son côté vidéo il reste dans
l'adn de sony donc sony affirme son adn
au travers ses smartphones est-ce que ça
va leur apporter du succès de la
réussite c'est compliqué à lire une
belle proposition de valeur moi je
trouve ça vraiment intéressant je pense
pas que ça se vende énormément je pense
que les gens qui vont chez sony
connaissent la marque aiment la marque
ils vont de par la qualité mais est à
côté de ça ils vont réussir à performer
dans les années à venir
c'est très dur à dire aujourd'hui au
nord 8 x ou chimie de physique chimie
1905 un problème quand tu changeras ton
smartphone tu pourras m'envoyer pour
être plus est pro bien tenté penses tu
que le prochain google pixels risque de
devancer le paie 30 pro niveau photo
d'ailleurs est-il de patron pour
toujours aussi performant pour la vidéo
de pétrole produits très performants
pour la photo pour la vidéo - les
smartphones qui font des gros focus sur
la vidéo se développe de plus en plus
d'ailleurs je n'en parlerai dans
quelques jours donc rester connectés et
abonnez vous maintenant est ce que le
prochain pixels risque de devancer le
petro gelé déjà vu le prochain succès
l'oeil déjà pu en main et croyez moi
je peux pas vous le dire mais où en sont
chiés omis avec leur smartphone pliable
qu'un je pense que c'est la meilleure
version xiaomi a montré un smartphone
pliable qui était un peu d'effet
d'annoncé pour dire on est dans la
course nous aussi on innove
mais pour l'instant il n'y a rien de
sortie rien annoncé donc je pense que
c'était un effet d'annonce je ne suis
pas sûr pour l'instant exposition de là
dessus parce que c'est quelque chose qui
est encore michel coûtera très cher
il sera pas forcément hyper rentable
dans l'immédiat pour xiaomi peut-être
dans les années à venir pour l'instant
wait and see
j'ai un chat au 1008 qui marche toujours
très bien j'aimerais savoir si ça vaut
le coup de changer pour un mineur et pro
s'ils marchent très bien garde-le je te
dirai toujours non ne pas surconsommer
quand il commencera à marché noir bien
alors par l'europe pour la prochaine
afin qu est-ce que tu penses que le one
+ risque d'être embêté comme huawei vu
que c'est une marque chinoise
non pas du tout en fait le problème ça
revient pas que ce soit une marque
chinoise le problème de huawei est plus
politique est notamment liée à la 5g
liés au board one plus ce n'est pas dans
les bandes 5 gêné kiffe pas des pannes
équipementier de la 5g donc ils n'auront
pas le même problème
les stages ne peuvent pas faire une
guerre non plus complète parce qu'il
faut savoir que eux dépendent de la
chine je pense d'ailleurs que les états
unis dépensent beaucoup plus de la chine
que la chine ne dépend des états je dis
donc ça serait une grosse erreur
politique et stratégique de bloquer tous
les produits chinois donc c'est une
évidence qui voit le plus ne rencontrera
pas de problème vis-à-vis des etats-unis
c'est un objectif d'acheter un nouveau
smartphone mais j'hésite de faire
l'achat maintenant ou à l'arrière de la
5g
est-ce qu'il serait mieux d'attendre
l'arrivée des smartphones compatibles 5g
en france ou de faire l'achat matures
alors ça dépend où tu habites la 5g ça
peut être intéressant mais si tu habites
à paris lyon ou marseille pour 2020
après je pense que pour les autres
villes il va falloir encore attendre un
petit peu pour que les ca se déploie
pour que les opérateurs proposent des
offres et ne soit pas non plus trop trop
trop cher donc pour l'instant si tu vas
leur nouvelle tout de suite tu peux
acheter un smartphone qui n'est pas sans
danger compatibles je pense que tu es
tranquille pour 2 3 ans sans aucun
problème quel téléphone pas trop cher à
mettre 150 euros pour faire des vidéos
sur youtube je me lance sur youtube
alors si quoi que tu te lances sur
youtube félicitations alors maintenant
ça sera avec un smartphone à moins de
350 euros pour te lancer sur youtube
tu vas pas avoir la meilleure qualité je
suis pas sûr qu'il faille aller sur un
smartphone dans ses budgets là je
t'aurais dit un iphone un iphone 10 ou
un iphone partir de l'iphone 8 pour
faire des vidéos été filmée
avec un petit micro externe à moins de
350 euros
j'ai peur que ce soit compliqué
regardent peut-être des fois tu peux
trouver des petites caméras 3d petit
cannon peut-être pas trop cher qui
peuvent être bien voir si tu peux
brancher un petit micro externe pense
que c'est peut-être là la meilleure
solution
ou alors une go pro de regarder plus de
ce côté là que du côté smartphones en
tout cas ça lui pourras-tu dans tes
vidéos faire des points vraiment plus
techniques sur les smartphones
d'optimisation de chaque os je pourrais
en fait l'idée si tu veux les eaux c'est
que je veux pas contre les autres trop
trop trop trop trop technique parce que
tout le monde est pas hyper a tassé par
le proto trop techniques et j'essaie de
plus de parler d' usage que du truc
hyper hyper technique alors après je
pourrais peut-être de temps en temps
avoir et si on veut tout hyper hyper
technique il ya de la presse spécialisée
qui pond coude est vraiment hyper hyper
technique voilà c'est tout pour cette
facture la femme mais elle était un
petit peu longue
j'espère qu'elle vous aura intéressé je
vous invite une fois de plus ça veut
dire tout ce que vous en pensez en
banque commente à poser toutes vos
questions sur la prochaine faq on se
retrouve très prochainement la semaine
pro gros crypte new york lisbonne y aura
plein de choses à dire on va les voir le
pixel 4 on va parler d'eux au pot on va
parler de go pro ça va être trop cool
vous embrasse
bisous et à demain de charles